What should I do about high blood calcines?
Calcines? Well, I don't know anything about this person who's asking this question,
but high blood calcines, so if that's the only thing abnormal on your blood test,
and you don't have any no disease, you have to, it's like any other test you have to dig to,
why, why, why, what's going on? So what's the most common cause of high blood calcium? It's
parathyroid tumor as the most cold cause. So your parathyroid glands right up here,
screen of hormone to help you get rid of calcium in your kidneys and retain calcium in your
kidneys. When you have high blood calcium, the most common cause of that is a tumor in the parathyroid
glands, and you need to get in right away and get that removed. You just have to, it's
something to play around with. I've seen multiple cases like this, just go in and get the surgery,
it's very simple, easy to do surgery, typically other patients, and you'll get that done.
With a person with a diagnosis of cancer, high blood calcium is typically indicative of
metastatic disease to the bone. So most metastatic cancers to the bone, when cancer metastasizes
to the bone, it's in person, it's breast cancer, and it metastasizes to the bone,
it's typically going to be a lytic cancer, it's going to be a lytic lesion. By that, I mean
cancer erodes away the bone, and by eroding away the bone, you're going to spill calcium into the
blood, you're going to have excess blood calcium bloodness. I don't have cancer,
and I don't know what it is, I'd go to get a check, could be parathyroid,
tumor, it could be, you have primary bone cancer, primary bone cancer can be lytic or plastic,
and could result in high blood calcium. Regardless, whatever you have abnormalities in your blood
tests, you should find out why, you know, by figuring out why, and it's good to require some
further testing. I can't tell you how many people that I talked to on a weekly basis that they
sent me their blood work, and I go, okay, what did you do this two months ago? Did you ever
address this, this, this, nobody after talked about it, but, okay, why would you run a blood test
on somebody if you don't, a, address the abnormalities correctly, and b,
formulate a plan to deal with those abnormalities, and c, retest to see if your plan worked. I
just, I don't get it. I have backgrounds sometimes. So, you see, lots of times,
with cancer patients with it. They have an edemia, and it's like, okay, what did, what did the doctor
do about this edemia? Well, nothing. Well, this is, I can't even use this blood work with six months
old. It could have changed drastically in that time. We need to do more blood work and see what's
going on now. I mean, whatever your blood work is a picture in time, and, and it tell, it gives you
clues of what could be going on. So, we want to figure out what is going on, and you have to dig to
that reason why.